sur le plan économique vont soir gérard
et de l'intégration économique des
réfugiés parce que c'est ça va être un
grand défi absolument c'est un défi pour
les réfugiés c'est un défi de toute
façon pour les immigrants c'est vrai
particulièrement à montréal au québec
par rapport aux autres provinces et aux
autres grandes villes
selon une étude du cyrano qui a été
publié il ya un an en novembre 2014 les
immigrants sont souvent des gens très
diplômés mais souvent diplômés à
l'étranger leur taux de chômage est
assez élevé particulièrement chez les
femmes il ya une hésitation des
employeurs également québécois à
embaucher des immigrants selon l'étude
et d'ailleurs le taux de chômage des
immigrants au québec est le plus élevé
au canada et le taux de chômage des non
immigrants au québec est le plus bas au
canada
ce qui fait dire donc à cette étude du
cirano que le québec est en dernière
position pays au chapitre de l'accès à
l'emploi chez les immigrants voilà le
contexte et je vais vous montrer des
chiffres pour montrer justement que le
chômage chez les immigrants est élevé
selon les dernières données disponibles
avec lé recensement de 2011 à montréal
le taux de chômage chez les immigrants
était de 11 et demi pour cent le double
des non immigrants quand on regarde
toronto et vancouver c'était carré
beaucoup plus serrée et ce chômage là et
il vit chez les immigrants récents
surtout surtout donc quand on parle des
migrants récents ce sont des gens qui
sont ici depuis cinq ans au moins au
québec 18 25% le taux de chômage en 2011
en ontario 14 et demi pour cent en
colombie en ondes en
colombie-britannique pendant 11 % on
voit clairement que ce défi
d'intégration au marché du travail est
un grand défi et dans le cas des
réfugiés
s'ajoute la difficulté bien sûr de la
langue ne maîtrisant pas pour la plupart
le français et l'anglais
l'enit traumatisme et tous absolument
merci gerald très intéressant